and
in this shot from ghostbusters afterlife
a terror dog stomps on paul rudd's car
but that's not cgi it's actually a
puppeteer wearing a mechanical terror
dog arm controlled by a series of cables
to make creatures like the terror dog
and this ghoulish skeleton
hyper-realistic makeup effects teams
have to juggle visual design classic
puppeteering and animatronics instead of
being an actor and giving a performance
it's getting nine people to get a
performance
making practical creatures look hyper
realistic requires plenty of trial and
error in the design phase this was
especially true for afterlife to stick
to the spirit of the original
ghostbusters the team had to modernize
the original terror dog from 1984 with
as little cgi as possible they started
with these maquettes miniature models
used to nail down a creature's look
before creating the actual on-screen
model maquettes also give the visual
effects team a real-life reference so
they can complete cg shots that are too
difficult to do practically like when
the terror dog runs through walmart this
is when aryan runs paint tests on a mock
head to determine which colors look best
on camera for example his team amped up
the lip color in the final version
and a more detailed reference head gives
a sense of what it'll look like under
movie lighting so if he's in warm light
you can tell he's more brown
but if he's in cooler light he's more
gray at the same time afterlife
animatronic designer bill sturgeon
conducted a movement test by connecting
a scaled-down 2d printout of the terror
dog to brass tubing a popsicle stick and
plastic cables this is how sturgeon
determines the creature's biggest and
most notable movements known as the
gross body move once a creature's look
and movements are solidified the makeup
effects team will then sculpt the final
design true to size for afterlife they
made a larger model of the dog out of
600 pounds of clay which served as the
mold for the actual animatronic so it
was key to get everything right down to
the crevices on its horns and skin aryan
cast the mold with foam latex a
departure from the modern standard of
silicone we opted to go with foam latex
because of the weight but it also moves
great in compression silicone would have
worked but it also would have made the
teardog about 500 pounds heavier than it
already is with the mechanics and
protective fiberglass shell the terror
dog ultimately weighed 450 pounds still
heavy but light enough to maneuver
softer foam latex wouldn't suffice for
every part of the creature like its
teeth which were made with acrylic so
they're actually hard yeah you do not
want to get bitten by one of these
the acrylic created a degree of
translucency similar to a real set of
teeth but it would be too brittle for
the dog's nails which needed to be
strong enough to endure the physical
demands of shooting so they used
urethane resin for light tough and
hollow nails they would get hit or
somebody would accidentally step on it
they wouldn't break so there's a lot of
thought that went into it these horns
were also made of the same resin as the
nails which let light in to look more
realistic on camera look at the
difference between the horns made during
paint tests and the final version it
just absorbs the light like a real horn
would the horns also needed to be sturdy
since they needed to be removable the
crew only made one terror dog
animatronic to stand in for both zuul
and vince clortho so they built the
horns with magnetic attachments which
could easily be swapped out these longer
horns were for the male and the shorter
ones were for the female terror dog but
for practical creatures to look
convincing they ultimately have to move
realistically
unlike more traditional puppeteering
animatronic work requires mechanized
motors known as servos which can be
programmed to create specific movements
instead of cables and strings they're
brought to life using controllers for
afterlife the terra dog would have to be
designed to fit all the servos inside
and there were a lot of them the terror
dog had 21 servos in its face alone to
allow for subtle expressions and one
mouth movement could take three people
to perform it because the mouth is so
big the servos have to move a lot of
material to make it look right for
example the servos needed the ability to
rotate and move a lot of skin around for
subtle movements such as blinking
squinting and sniffing so the foam latex
was much thinner in the face and neck
than the body if you know a part's gonna
move more than something else you might
make deeper wrinkles you can see that
feature in the neck which arya knew
would be heavily utilized and gave
sturgeon the ability to imitate a very
specific head turn the original puppet
did in 1984. it could even look like it
was actually eating out of a bag of dog
food during this moment the terror dog
also needed to open its mouth wide
meaning placement of the jaw's pivot
point was also key we had to figure it
out can be too high can be too low it
would look odd
[Music]
going down the rest of the animatronics
body the foam latex could be much
thicker since it had less animatronic
movement but it still required some
crucial additions sturgeon placed a
linear actuator in the beast's stomach
this specific servo would only push out
in a straight line to mimic realistic
breathing this full body shot of the
terror dog right here that's actually
cgi as aryan and his team never created
its back half for real instead the top
half was attached to a cart with two
weights on it the cart made it easier to
move the heavy puppet around so it could
be placed on the hood of a car in one
shot puppeteers will also rely on
traditional cables when the movement
calls for it like with this snarl one of
the most complicated movements for the
dog
sturgeon used cables to work alongside
the servos and the lips to really nail
the look that's actually a number of
servos working at the same time to give
it a left and right side and
snarl and in these quick shots of a
skeleton minor the ghost needed to
handle a coffee mug so creature designer
tanner white designed this cable system
that connected his hand to the miner's
hand each of the joints was the real
limit of the actual hand joint so it
didn't
move when it shouldn't so each finger
correlates to the finger movement and
since you use your own hand strength you
can grasp things a lot stronger than you
could with a radio control to grip
something like the cup here basically
you just pull all the fingers and the
wrist movement down so that he's
grasping and then if you let go
drops giving life to these creatures can
mean some very uncomfortable positions
for the puppeteers while the miners eyes
were radio controlled off camera ren had
to cable operate its brows and other
parts of its face through the bottom of
the puppet that meant crouching under
the diner counter to avoid ending up on
camera
for some moves it's easier just to
puppeteer a single part of the anatomy
on its own based on what's shown on
camera like in the close-up shot where
the terror dog stomps its foot down on
the hood of red's car to get the full
force aryan created a separate terror
dog leg made of the exact same materials
puppeteer ron binion grabbed onto a
metal armature inside the leg to move it
but the leg was so big that a human arm
couldn't reach the foot so cables were
used to give convincing ankle and toe
movements when i'm moving it i want to
move it in arcs that are similar to what
the tarot dog would do on the day of
shooting i was up pretty high same way
and trying to get myself
out of the shot i'm looking at a spot on
the car hood where where i'm aiming but
also trying to keep myself out of the
frame and
if i'm pushing down you can still see
the foot adjusting and moving and
flexing as the creature would be you
know shifting on its weight and sort of
coming down hard and just like an actor
a practical creature needs some makeup
before being camera ready that can be as
simple as a glossy shine on the skin or
some drool
so the crew applied a product called
ultra slime to the dog's lips on set so
we would do this just before the take
and set it so in other words if you
would start moving it would string and
start stretching you can see it just
starts like dripping but you got to
catch it at the right moment but that's
the fun part about it
the actors loved it i remember paul rudd
jumping up and down and gary being so so
happy to see something physically on set
which is so rare these days